so I think one of our problems one of
our big problems one of our primary
problems in the culture today is
cowardice moral cowardice especially I
think we you know we can look at the
state of things in our world and we
could try to provide ourselves with
excuses and come up with reasons as to
why it is the way it is while dancing
around the real issue and the real issue
is that most of us are cowards plain and
simple
not all of us certainly but many most
and so you may be wondering well how do
I know if I'm a coward how do I know if
I'm a moral coward what's the test
I think we can we can figure out if we
ourselves are moral cowards by asking
ourselves just a few questions okay so
this is what this is what we could it's
what you can ask yourself when was the
last time I did something that I really
didn't want to do but I did it anyway
because it was morally right or the
inverse of that when was the last time I
didn't do something that I really really
wanted to do and had the opportunity to
do but did not do it because it would
have been immoral or when was the last
time that I took some kind of moral
stand that I knew was gonna bring about
humiliation and maybe even worse
consequences than that and especially a
moral stand that I knew could
potentially alienate me from even my own
friends and people on my side
it's on I'm not talking about going on
Facebook and writing some Republican
things you know some some talking point
from fox news that you know all your
Republican friends are going to agree
with no I'm not talking about that that
takes no courage whatsoever I'm talking
about taking a stand on something that
may alienate you from everybody
practically where you have no guarantees
that anyone around you is going to agree
I think if we honestly asked ourselves
those questions
if we're really honest about it I'm so
I'm asking you like really think about
this ask yourself ask yourself honestly
those questions just as I am asking
myself those questions
and I think if we do that a great many
of us would have to admit that we've
never done any of those things or not
done them as the case may be
I think we're being really honest many
of us cannot think of one actual example
of us doing something we really really
didn't want to do but doing it because
it was moral or especially not doing
something that we really really wanted
to do but we didn't do it because it was
immoral and I really think that most of
us probably can't think of one honest
example of us in our own lives
standing up taking a stand and really
going out on a limb and exposing
ourselves to humiliation and other
consequences because of it I just I
think most of us can't come up with an
example of that and I feel safe making
that assumption because if a majority of
us had the willingness to act with moral
courage that we wouldn't be in the shape
that we're in in our society we better
we've arrived at this point through the
consent and often the active
participation of most people that's just
the sad reality and that's why I'm not a
populist
okay I know populism is very popular
these days
not surprisingly but I can't jump on
board with this kind of right-wing
populism thing because what I notice in
populism is this is this instinct to
blame everything on institutions and on
the kind of elite shadowy villains in
academia and the government and the
media and they they're the ones they did
everything it's their fault and it's
true that they deserve quite a lot of
the blame and I spend a lot of time
blaming them for things and they deserve
it but it's not just them
the sad fact is that most regular people
participate have participated in the
degradation and destruction of our
culture and if they were not
participating or at least consenting to
it through silence if most of us weren't
doing it that we wouldn't be in this
state
all of those elites and everything they
only have the power that we give them
Hollywood only has any power because we
if we didn't pay attention to Hollywood
it would have no power whatsoever it
also wouldn't have any money if we
didn't give them money we all sit back
like how does Hollywood have so much
power this is ridiculous
meanwhile we're giving them we're just
handing our we're literally handing our
cash to Hollywood and saying I can't
figure out why Hollywood is so powerful
I'm so sick of Hollywood and yet oh what
is that for the movie ticket to $27 well
here you go I mean and then we go in and
we vote these people into office and
then we say I can't figure out where do
these politicians came from come from I
can't figure out why they're controlling
everything and then we complain about
academia jiayou academia is destroying
society it meanwhile we push our kids
into these unique liberal colleges and
universities and we send our kids to
public school we're like pushing we're
pushing our kids into the academic
system while complaining about academia
so yes I blame us we are not innocent
little victimized snowflakes who are
just trying to live our lives and are
being bullied by those mean elites
that's not what's happening
so I mentioned yesterday just by way of
example the story of the two biological
boys who were permitted to compete
against and ultimately defeat girls at a
state track and field championship in
Connecticut and I talked about this on
the show yesterday the reason I bring it
up again is because it's it's what it's
what got me thinking about the issue of
courage this story is just a perfect
example a perfect microcosm of how
things always go in our culture when you
have radical leftist imposing their will
on moral cowards
so as I said yesterday just in that
example just as one example if every
parent who silently disagreed with
allowing boys to steal medals from their
daughters and every coach who privately
felt disgusted by it in every school
official who harbored serious
reservations about the whole thing in
their minds if they all would just speak
up
and refused to participate in or
facilitate any competition that involves
boys then the problem would be solved
just like that and that's the case for
most of these problems
if everybody who silently disagreed with
it would just say something and do
something about it
the problem would go away
it would really be that easy for most of
these things
in that case too many people were afraid
too many of them are cowards
so they let they let the smallest
minority pushing the craziest ideology
prevail
because they were too afraid
I hear all the time about the so-called
silent majority there is supposedly a
silent majority who allegedly opposes
and despises radical left ISM you know
they they're not on board with any of
this with any of this stuff
they're the silent majority and
conservatives will often talk about this
majority with some kind of like pride
you know what conservatives will talk
about this majority as if we're proud of
the fact we'll say well you know we're
the ones really in the majority but
we're the ones with there's more of us
than there are then did you know that
well I don't understand the pride
because if this majority exists and I
think it probably does then their status
as a majority just makes their cowardice
all the more shameful I mean you're
telling me that we that we're in the
majority and we know we're in the
majority yet we still won't say anything
we still sit back and let all this stuff
happen we've allowed the the relativists
and the hedonist to up end and reshape
and reform and destroy our civilization
and dictate terms to us and get their
way on almost everything even to the
point of intruding into our daughters
bathrooms and sports teams and what do
we do in response we just kind of shake
our head and we furrow our brows and we
we we mutter quietly to each other and
we complain about it whispering in our
in our living rooms to each other with
nobody you know we're whispering to each
other our living room to the doors lock
we're looking around and hey you know I
really disagree with this transgender
stuff you know III honestly I think it's
crazy but so much coming how many
schools have instituted these insane
transgender policies while a majority of
parents and teachers and everybody
opposes it yet says nothing
that you've got this in in these cases
with the transgender stuff there's
definitely a silent majority who are
totally against it and think it's nuts
but they won't say it they just stay
quiet and that's just one example I mean
in my piece yesterday I mentioned the
story of a crossfit executive now this
is an example on the other end of the
spectrum this is an example of courage
this is what courage looks like
so a crossfit executive got fired after
saying that gay pride parades and gay
pride festivals are sinful which is true
they are sinful and he said this on his
own twitter account and he was fired for
it but that that made me think well how
many communities have hosted these
sinful spectacles known as pride parades
while the majority of residents in these
communities are are absolutely opposed
to the whole thing but they don't say a
word of protest against it they just
they just kind of stand off on the side
and maybe even they maybe they even wave
one of the rainbow flags just so nobody
because they don't want anyone to know
that they're opposed to this in their
head they're so terrified how many how
many people feel very upset about the
Holocaust of the unborn that happens in
abortion clinics across our nation and
the 1 million babies that are killed
every year and yet although they feel a
set upset by it they do and say nothing
in opposition to it
how many people complain as I said about
complain about Hollywood and all the
filth on TV and everything yet they keep
on watching it watching the filth and
letting their children watch and on and
on and on and on we let all of this
stuff happen we stand by while it
happens we say nothing and then we claim
that our silence is rooted in some kind
of principle this is my favorite thing
when conservatives are trying to justify
their cowardice in their silence and so
they'll they'll try to make it about
freedom about about respecting other
people's privacy and they'll say well I
don't agree with it but we all have
freedom and you know the free market and
freedom and free market that's pickup
look I believe in freedom and I believe
in the free market but it has become a
crutch for cowardly wusses in the
conservative movement who just want day
one they lean on that for everything to
give them an excuse so they don't have
to fight back ever about anything so
like for instance I remember I wrote an
article few months ago about about porn
and I said that porn should be banned it
should be illegal which is a position
the idea that it should be illegal to
publish hardcore pornography that
children that like eight-year-olds can
access now that is not a radical
position or at least up until very
recently it would not have been
considered a radical position and almost
anyone who considers them conservative
could consider that consider themselves
conservative and certainly anyone who
consider themselves Christian would
agree obviously yes that stuff should be
illegal by I wrote this article and what
I found is that the majority of
conservatives in the audience
absolutely disagreed with making
hardcore pornography they on on the
basis of freedom they said we know we
need its freedom no so yes because of
freedom we have to let our
eight-year-olds watch hardboard
pornography that's that's what we need
it's freedom that's what Thomas
Jefferson would have wanted you know
something I know this is gonna be very
scandalous for a lot of conservatives in
the audience
I don't care what Thomas Jefferson would
have wanted
for sin is not God now I actually don't
agree I think that our founding fathers
never intended for the First Amendment
to cover hardcore pornography and if
they could have looked into a crystal
wall and saw a situation where the first
amendment was being used to to to to
give pornographers the the freedom to to
to you know shove this filth into the
faces of children I think our founding
fathers would have been very much
against that and the fact that there
were decency laws on the books in almost
every state up until recently I think
that kind of speaks to that but but but
here's the point yeah I think it's
pretty clear that the First Amendment
does not protect hardcore pornography
and it does not exclude individual
communities and states it doesn't
prevent communities and states from
having standards of decency and decency
laws
so that's as far as the law goes I think
that's clear
as far as what our founding fathers
individually would have wanted in their
own heads I don't care it doesn't matter
doesn't matter to me I mean Thomas
Jefferson was also I mean he ripped
apart the Bible and made his own Bible
okay
so that's what that's from a moral and
spiritual perspective that's the kind of
guy we were dealing with so I don't
really care what his moral and spiritual
opinions were all right that as a
Christian what we need to be what we
need to be worried about is what would
Jesus it's not like what were Thomas
Jefferson what were the founding fathers
priorities what was Jesus's priorities
what would Jesus want for our country
and our community and our children
that's who we should be worried about
Jesus is God not the people on Mount
Rushmore not the founding fathers not
the people that you know signed the
Declaration of Independence they were
all they were great men they were not
gods
servant movement what we've done is we
have made a religion out of
we've made kind of a national religion
for ourselves and we have pushed Jesus
out of the frame completely
but as Christians I think it's clear
that our first priority is to shape the
kind of country and the kind of
civilization the kind of community that
God wants for us
that's what we should be doing
and that means
standing up against filth and degeneracy
and in all this stuff
do you want to live in a culture of
Filth and degeneracy where your children
are eaten alive by this garbage is that
the kind of culture you want if not say
something don't tell me why I don't want
it but we can't do anything because of
freedom no that's not freedom you're
talking about it's cowardice
so do something stand up
the fact is that most of us are exactly
like the parents coaches and officials
who stood off on the sidelines politely
clapping while a couple of dudes cheated
and humiliated their daughters that's
what most of them were doing their words
they were just kind of did a fake smile
on their face and they were just
standing up on the silent yeah okay good
job you go girl
I mean why why why weren't their parents
running on to the running on to the
track itself and saying no I'm not gonna
let this race go up why wasn't why
didn't some girls dad go up and confront
these dudes these cheaters and say hey
buddy you got the wrong track the boys
track meet is that way okay now get off
why didn't somebody's dad do that do you
think let me ask is like 50 years ago if
this had had this happened 50 years ago
imagine like your grandfather okay um if
50 years ago you've got to do you got
some muscle-bound dude that shows up at
a girl's track need 50 years ago it says
yeah I'm gonna race against the girl and
they're a bunch of dads in the audience
how do you think the dads want to
respond to that you think they would
have just sat back and said well we
can't do anything it's freedom you know
freedom yeah it's what Thomas Jefferson
would have wanted no those those dads
would have walked right onto that track
and said hey but Jeff no you got here
but we don't do that anymore and why is
that because because we're afraid and
what do we say we're afraid of I think
the month one of the excuses that you
always hear is well we'll lose our jobs
well I think there's quite a bit that we
could do to stand for our convictions
without getting to the point where we
might lose our jobs like losing our jobs
is here and we're over here we could we
got a lot of room to cover before we
have to worry about losing your job but
even if that is a risk and maybe it is
in some situations for some jobs maybe
it is a risk
okay maybe that's a risk we have to take
Jesus says we have to be willing to give
up our lives for the truth so if we
won't even give up our jobs potentially
for the truth then how far are we from
living like Jesus told us to live but
the thing is that's not even the real
fear isn't because it's not just about
jobs I think people are mostly afraid of
social alienation they're afraid of
humiliation and it's natural to feel
that fear those things but really when
you think about it who cares about that
who cares what these cackling drones
think about you so people laugh at you
who cares
you what it what why be afraid of that
our lives are not being threatened we're
not being called upon to demonstrate a
huge amount of courage the kind of
courage that you need to demonstrate
when you're when your actual life is at
risk our lives aren't at risk
nobody's coming to our houses and
killing us because of our opinions maybe
eventually we'll be at that point but
well actually we're never going to be at
that point at this rate because there's
no reason for us to ever get to that
point ow our you know our ideological
enemies and the enemies of God in our
culture they don't need to kill us
because we're no threat to them we're
just we're too busy watching Netflix and
minding our own business so why are they
gonna come kill us
we're not worth killing basically the
Christians in the Middle East they're
worth killing from the perspective of
the Satanic persecutors of the church
because they are they're on fire with
the faith and they're courageous and
they're strong Christians and so the
enemies of the church say well we got me
all we can do is kill them the enemies
of the church in this country they look
at us and they just laugh they say you
guys are no threat you're not gonna do
anything I mean you won't even stop
watching Disney movies yeah you complain
about Disney you can't even bring
yourself to do that yes you're no threat
now you're worried we're gonna kill you
why would we ever do that
so it's not a lot of courage that we
need to demonstrate I think we need to
demonstrate just a little bit just a
little tiny speck of courage and if we
all had that if we all had just our
little speck if we all came equipped
into every situation with just that
little speck of courage like you can't
hardly even see it but if we all have
that
and we're willing in any situation to
demonstrate just that small speck of
courage for only even just a few seconds
that's what most most situations call
for a small amount of courage that you
will demonstrate for a very short amount
of time
and if we were willing to do that
think everything would change
so that's my
challenge to you and to myself
because by the way I'm not I'm saying
all this I'm talking to myself as well
not just to you I'm talking to all of us
so I'm using a word we and us
I certainly don't put myself forward as
a
some sort of monument of courage at all
so this is a challenge for all of us
if we if we were willing to if we're
willing to just have a little bit of
courage or short amount of time
little courage in small spurts basically
for willing to do that then I think
things would change so let's give it a
try it's worth a shot
and who knows it could be fun it could
be exciting that's the other thing I
think when you if you live with courage
your life is also more exciting and
unpredictable right so let's let's let's
just try it and see what happens thanks
for watching thanks for listening
everybody Godspeed